si vous regardez le vote néo-démocrate
le vote du NPD qui a diminué
si vous comparez le vote démocrate de
2019 et 2021 le Nouveau Parti
démocratique a réellement un problème un
problème parce que les électeurs nés
démocrates se disent on est né au
démocrate mais on se pince le nez pour
voter libéral afin de bloquer la voix à
Pierre Pollet et la dernière chose que
je veux dire sur Oxford juste pour
donner une comparaison québécoise le
côté darksford c'est comme le Saguenay
Lac Saint-Jean imaginez par acheter un
candidat du plateau de Montréal au
Saguenay de Lac Saint-Jean c'est ce que
les conservateurs ont fait ils ont pas
acheté donc un petit rappel parachuter
des candidats du plateau au Saguenay Lac
Saint-Jean il y a des risques là-dedans
et je veux dire tout et je veux dire
tout ce que les autres ne disent pas le
comté dOxford c'est un comté qui est
majoritairement blanc le candidat
conservateur l'issue de la communauté
sud-asiatique donc une minorité visible
il a du pain sur la planche parce que il
aurait dû gagner par 20 ou même 30% de
différence il a du pain sur la planche
pour maintenant qu'il a déménagé avec sa
famille pour convaincre les gens que il
est la bonne personne pour les
représenter parlons de parachuté Maxime
Bernier dans portage lisse garde donc
c'est son Manitoba monsieur Bernier chef
du Parti populaire du Canada essayer de
se faire élire là regardez le résultat
65% pour le député conservateur pour
l'élu conservateur Maxime Bernier a 17%
c'est 4% 4 points et demi de moins
qu'aux élections de 2021 pour son parti
donc le chef performe moins bien que
c'est une candidat que je pense dans
cette circonscription pour le Parti
populaire du Canada en 2021 quelle
lecture vous faites de ça pour monsieur
Bernier Jean-François il s'accroche il
nous dit on va l'entendre
Maxime Bernier dans son analyse des
résultats écoutons monsieur ben
cycle des mondes parties là ne fait que
trois et par exemple le Parti vert du
Canada après
28 ans ils ont eu 2% du vote et nous on
a eu 5%, le parti croit malgré malgré ce
que des gens voudraient on est là pour
rester
on est là pour rester on sait pas dans
quelle prochaine circonscription on va
se présenter mais lisez tout on dirait
ok Jean-François votre vos réflexions
bon alors le parti croit si continue à
croire à -4% à chaque élection il va
finir en dessous de zéro c'est un genre
de croissance et récession
alors je vais expliquer quelque chose
aux téléspectateurs que quand on parle
pas souvent politique c'est
évidemment ces catastrophique pour lui
mais s'il devait démissionner qu'est-ce
qui ferait du reste de sa vie
[Rires]
Canada cause tout cause il y a
suffisamment de remboursement de vote
par le fédéral pour pouvoir se payer un
salaire à vie même si plafonne même si
rien reste un petit peu il est capable
de se payer un salaire à vie en restant
chef de ce micro-partie qui est sa
petite entreprise qui l'a créé et donc
il a le choix entre garder salaire là
continuez à rencontrer des gens qui sont
d'accord avec lui puis à faire des
discours puis parfois passer à la télé
ou rentrer chez lui c'est où chez lui
est-ce que c'est la bosse c'est le
Manitoba c'est Ottawa c'est Montréal
j'ai trouvé une autre job bah c'est pas
un très bon CV là pour trouver une autre
job alors moi je pense qu'une des
raisons pour lesquelles il va être dans
le portrait longtemps c'est parce que il
y a une jobstd puis un bon boss lui
réflexion sur Maxime
François vient de dire la vérité des
vérités la réalité c'est même pas le
dépanneur du coin embaucherait Maxime
Bernier aujourd'hui et pour oui non
écoutez regardez doué partie Maxime
Bernier comment est-ce que quelqu'un qui
marchait dans les rues elle est au
parades pour la fierté gay à une époque
mais c'est est-ce que tu peux être plus
hypocrite que ça sur des valeurs
fondamentales un jour marché dans les
rues la parade gay pour appuyer la
communauté LGBTQ et l'autre jour faire
campagne contre cette même communauté
donc Maxime Bernier il va continuer à
vivre avec un parachute sur le dos il
lui reste encore 334 côtés où il peut se
présenter il se donne 25 ans il a dit le
Parti vert ça lui a pris 28 ans donc il
est déjà je pense à sa cinquième ou à sa
sixième année il lui reste un autre
quart de siècle pour avoir une job comme
dit Jean-François et
espérer de gagner sa vie avec les dons
des contribuables Françoise vouliez
parler de NDJ puis le temps file donc on
va y aller sur Notre-Dame de
grâce-houëtmand victoire du Parti
libéral donc il conserve cette
circonscription qui est où Marc Garnaud
avait été élu en 2021 c'est Anna gainé
qui est en train de se faire un prénom
c'est la fille de Bob gainer l'ancien
joueur de hockey quand même -3 points
c'est dans à peu près dans une espèce de
marge d'erreur on conclut donc que ce
que marguerno disait sur le ressac de la
Loi sur les langues officielles que ça
pouvait avoir notamment dans ces
circonscriptions parce qu'il avait
combattu Maussac est pas mal faible en
tout cas si on regarde les pourcentages
du parti libérale vos réflexions
là-dessus Françoise et puis je trouve
intéressant de voir que ce sont les
Verts qui sont allés ramasser
pratiquement tout le surplus parce que
tous les autres partis ont baissé ce qui
m'intéresse aussi de voir Dimitri par
l'aide du vote du LPD c'est vrai qu'il
va falloir que le NPD se pose de
sérieuses questions parce que après son
avec le gouvernement libéral qui permet
à ce gouvernement là d'être un
gouvernement relativement stable d'être
là pour beaucoup plus d'années au lieu
d'avoir l'espèce d'hystérie collective
de députés à savoir si on tombe au
premier vote de confiance qui qui sort
ensemble de savoir que tu es là de façon
continue ça permet au gouvernement en
place de respirer mais il sent pas
gagner quoi que ce soit de ce que Jack
meeting passe son temps à nous dire
c'est à dire que si on a les garderies à
10 pièces si on a l'assurance médicament
ou si on a l'assurance dentaire etc etc
c'est grâce à eux ben les gens
ressemblent pas vouloir être
reconnaissants et le retourner
l'ascenseur par ailleurs dans Notre Dame
de Grâce ou westmans ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est justement il y a une
grosse communauté à le fun anglophone et
qui finit deuxième dans cette
circonscription c'est le NPD et non pas
le Parti conservateur et si
c'est presque de l'égalité mais ça
devrait être des circonscriptions ça
devrait être des circonscriptions dans
lesquelles polyèvre s'il était peut-être
un petit peu plus modéré pourraient
empirer
mais au moins faire mieux que le NPD ici
mana active
tu peux mettre une chaise libérale ça va
être élu je suis d'accord mais au moins
performe va chercher
ce sont les verres mais vous allez me
dire que c'est le Cochette des Verts
mais avant cette partie là il y a
personne qui savait cette équipe qu'au
chef des verres il y en a qui savent
même pas c'est qui la chef des verres
alors c'est quelque part il y a quand
même matière à réflexion mais c'est une
grosse victoire pour un againer et je
dirais juste pour brasser quelque chose
là mais avec l'arrivée de nos gainer il
faudrait peut-être que qui va d'après
moi prendre beaucoup de place dans
l'avenir au parti libérale du Canada à
travers le gouvernement différents rôles
c'est une bonne amie de Justin Trudeau
c'est une très proche elle a
y avoir un remaniement ministériel ah
ben ça c'est clair qu'ils veulent
n'avoir un parce que là il y a trop de
ministres incompétents dans ce
gouvernement là mais en même temps ça va
faire réfléchir des gens par exemple
comme Joël lightband qui performe qui
était vu comme une superstar lors de sa
première élection et qui semble faire un
peu de sur place peut-être que c'est son
avenir et peut-être plus du côté du
Parti libéral du Québec on sait jamais
alors l'arrivée d'Anna c'est peut-être
l'arrivée de Joël ailleurs là pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI